Aloha everyone from beautiful Hawaii
we are here on the island of Oahu where
I did a lot of my growing up
as you know Hawaii means so much to my
family and me and the traditions of our
Ohana or aiinga as we say in Samoa were
shaped by these incredible Islands the
Pacific Islands and their cultures
inspired a very special Story one that
you all know very well and that story is
drum roll please
[Music]
are so excited and happy to announce
that a live-action reimagining of Moana
is in the works Moana Grandma tala the
music the dance te fiti Pua the pig the
village the beautiful powerful ocean and
one more what's that guys oh Yours Truly
hey hey the chicken kidding hey hey is
going to be in it but of course Maui
will be in a two
as many of you may not know the
brilliant team at Disney Animation my
partners we found so much inspiration
from Maui in the Mana and the presence
of my late grandfather the legendary
High Chief Peter Maivia he would walk in
light up the room the energy the tattoos
the hair the bod when you're staring at
a demigod thank you sorry I get caught
up in the moment
so as you guys can see perfect timing as
the sun comes out just how deep the
story is for me because in a way when I
bring Maui to life I'm doing it in the
spirit of my grandfather so uh it's
still very early in the process there's
so much more work to be done but until
then there is one more thing that I need
to kick this journey off right hey girls
you want to get uh that special thing
that Daddy needs wow you guys are
Daddy's daughters you are so strong
thank you guys so much we're gonna go in
the ocean yes
you guys want ice cream
yeah see so Daddy's Maui
laughs